we are off and running on this friday
night in chicago for the sox and royals
game number one
of three he went merrifield to lead off
for kansas city
wrapped to third johann moncada
with a scoop from jose for route number
one so with one on two out
comes ryan o'hern now the one-two pitch
to o'hara
high pop-up on the infield right side
who wants it
it's gonna be tim anderson on that side
of the bag at second he'll make the
catch
inning over danny duffy who's always
done well against the white sox in his
career and has been
great in his last three against chicago
one out eloy jimenez
little tapper duffy can't get it and so
eloy is safe
he was destined for an infield single
that it bad jose brady the cleanup
hitter
jimenez runs and he challenged him with
a fastball
two strikeouts in the inning for duffy
one hit one left and after one
no score michael franco leads off
that is drilled toward right center
field and michael franco is going to
have another extra base hit
he'll be at second base with nobody out
in the second inning now league's
hitting 172
and he's gonna try and do it with a bunt
and it's a good one and lopez just kind
of gave up on it
so alex gets the job done and then some
he gets franco to third and he's on
gordon takes second so it's second and
third with two outs now and cam
gallagher
a little pop up on the infield right
side it'll be jose abreu back pedaling
to make the catch
on the infield dirt and the inning is
over nice job there by lopez to pitch
around the first two men
on unlimited potential
there is truly nothing he can't do and
when he starts to get confidence
to take the first pitch on occasion he's
going to even be better
luiz drills this ball right field and
god bring him home took the first pitch
he's going to be better that's eight
home runs 19 driven in
and astonishing power as he is a huge
ball
of talent that's yet to be realized he
doesn't know how good he can be
sucks on top white sox have a
one-nothing lead but merefill will lead
things off in the third inning for the
royals
whit gets on top of one and drives it to
deep left field
jimenez turns and it is back into the
bleachers
so whit answers the white sox home run
with his
sixth and retired one in the third
kansas city with runners at first and
second here nobody out
and ryan o'hearn is the batter lined
into right center field and o'hearn
comes through again with a runner in
scoring position
and the royals will take the lead dozier
scores solaire goes to third
and the royals lead 2-1 in the third
monday in 1-2
little tapper out in front of the plate
lopez has to hurry
and east him inning over
and here's jimenez who was on with an
infield single his first time up
back to the middle and that's lopez and
he makes a nice play
the braves got a nine home run
ripped to right center field jose's got
another gap worthy baseball
as he chugs into second base add one to
the reel lead off double in the fourth
and now he gets luis robert who took a
change up
to the opposite field jammed him back to
duffy
high throw robert can really run but he
is
out oh yeah what a
pick me up the tying runs aboard so
here's eloy
and he hits a high fly ball into deep
center field
backing up his merrifield he's gonna run
out of room and this one's gone into the
shrubbery in center field
eloy jimenez with one swing has the
white sox in front three to two here in
the fifth start of the sixth inning
gordon at first base
mode to see the batter butt popped up
over the mound and that thing hits the
ground there's a play at second
out made a total scramble behind the
mound
and the sucks do get an out on gordon
and
tim and jose they can only laugh two on
two out
danny mendic check swing that ball gets
away it's a strike three and danny ends
up at first base
base is loaded everything was on pause
and then danny peeled away
to reach first the bases are loaded as
the sox look for a little insurance
there they go three and two nomar takes
upstairs
nicely done to driving a run and the sox
add another it's four to two a
one-out walk and that will bring the
tying run to the plate and jorge solaire
who's had a lot of success
against white sox pitching
lined into deep right field that ball
carries it is gone and jorge solaire
ties the game with an opposite field
home run oh man
he shot that ball out of here and the
bases are loaded for the sox and johann
moncada against barlow
3-2 again there's a fast ball ripped to
right field and the sox take the lead
yo on moncado wins the battle and it's
five to four
running for his base michael franco is
one for four with a double
lined into left center field that's
going to roll deep
robert does a great job of cutting it
off
and in doing so and now franco's in a
rundown on the right side
and he is going to be safe and now
a thorough play and grundel was not
watching can you believe it
royals have tied the game at five ian
kennedy to yasmani grandal
yasmani in the air right field way
back and bring him home
good night guaranteed right field
grundel
walks it off and it's 6'5 the sox are in
first place